le 23
2008 ma vie
glee
d'une vie d'entrepreneur qui
généralement plutôt empreint de
confiance à une vie d'homme politique
qui est plutôt empreinte de défiance je
me retrouve dans le siège d'un ancien
président de la république d'un ancien
président du conseil à la tête d'une
ville emblématique et je suis dans un
tourbillon de celui qui n'avait jamais
rêvé de ça jamais imaginé qu'il
deviendrait d'hommes politiques jamais
eu envie non plus de devenir un homme
politique alors pourquoi est il faut
remonter six mois avant six mois avant
je suis à istanbul mes affaires et mon
entreprise m'a amené à voyager beaucoup
à travers le monde et ce dimanche soir
je reçois un coup de fil d'un de mes
enfants de ma fille aînée qui me dit
papa tu sais je vais pouvoir voter aux
prochaines élections mais probablement
je ne voterai pas je lui dis c'est telle
victoire jeudi victoire il faut voter
c'est un devoir civique c'est important
mais il me dit je ne fais pas confiance
aux hommes politiques ah et je lui dit
écoute en qui tu as confiance mais j'ai
confiance en mon père en mes parents
j'ai confiance en toi et je lui dise
tout ton de la boutade écoute battu
votera pour moi est ce qu'elle est
devenue une boutade m'a emmené dans une
aventure que je n'imaginais pas puisque
six mois après j'ai été élu maire de
cette belle ville emblématique de
neuilly sur seine dans une campagne très
tendue dans une campagne très compliqué
parce que je n'ai au cours de cette
campagne voulu céder à aucun parti aucun
un menteur a aucun soutien autre que mes
électeurs et j'ai découvert que même en
politique la confiance pouvait naître la
confiance pouvait prospérer de manière
très saine très authentique en dehors
des machines politicienne jusque dans
une ville comme met ma ville de neuilly
alors mais si je vous raconte cette
petite aventure de mon itinéraire mon
parcours politique c'est parce que le
monde politique est probablement celui
qui attise le plus de défiance quand on
regarde les baromètres en france comme à
l'étranger sur le monde politique on
voit que
il est en bas du tableau on fait
confiance aux patrons de pme ont fait
confiance au personnel médical ont fait
confiance aux associations ont fait
confiance à plein de monde mais la
politique elle est tout en bas alors que
comme le design filosofo au début du 20e
siècle la politique devrait être élevé
au niveau de la roue de la science parce
que c'est notre vie parce que c'est
notre quotidien parce que c'est la vie
de nos enfants parce que c'est notre
avenir parce que c'est la prospérité de
là où on vit or la politique elle est
tout en bas et elle souffre terriblement
de ce déficit de confiance et en danse
ouvre tous parce que finalement quand il
n'y a pas de confiance il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'énergie il n'y a pas beaucoup
de confiance il n'y a pas beaucoup de
mouvements quand il n'y a pas beaucoup
de confiance il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'espérance et donc ce que je voulais
partager avec vous c'est qu'elles sont
finalement ces vecteurs de confiance
qu'est ce qui a fait que dans une
campagne de six mois en dehors des
appareils politiques malgré tout dans ce
terrain politique extrêmement précaire
la confiance a pris dessous et les gens
se sont totalement mobilisés pour me
soutenir et pour m'amener à la tête de
cette belle ville et donc je retiens
trois éléments trois éléments qui sont
très personnelles mais que je partage
avec vous trois vecteurs de confiance
qui à mon avis ont été décisifs
le premier vecteur
ce sont
ce sont les convictions tous comment on
pourrait croire à quelqu'un qui ne
croient pas en grand chose comment
donner notre confiance à quelqu'un qui
n'est pas lisible sur ses convictions
sur ce en quoi il croit sur ce qu'il
fait avancer pourquoi s'en vont on n'a
pas confiance aux hommes politiques
c'est parce que vous sait pas trop
quelle est leur cap on sait que ils
peuvent changer de destination on sait
que finalement leur conviction les
valeurs sont plutôt une variable
d'ajustement que ce qu'il ait fait
avancer et moi je crois que les
convictions elle transfigure l'action
quand on agit à londres des convictions
qui nous portent l'action un sens et ce
sens il est communicatif et la confiance
se fait à l'aune du sens que chacun peut
percevoir de l'action qu'on mène donc là
les convictions dans ce cas elle
transfigure notre action son élément
fondamental de la confiance en politique
comme dans toutes les actions que les
uns et les autres on peut mener deuxième
vecteur de confiance l'audace là aussi
une grande grand auteur du 20e siècle
philosophe même que le général de gaulle
avait à ses côtés à londres en 43 à qui
il avait demandé de l'aider à préparer
le redressement de la france et qui lui
demander sur quelle base finalement la
france pourrait se redresser et elle a
dit au général de gaulle cette jeune
philosophe elle a dix qui est à plus le
plus à craindre pour la france en
quarante cinq ans au moment où on est
payant espérer que la france se libérer
c'est de tomber dans une morne
uniformité et donc l'audace c'est ce qui
nous permet tous individuellement
collectivement de ne pas tomber dans
cette morne uniformité dans tout ce qui
participe de la routine de
l'aplatissement de nos sociétés de
l'aplatissement de nos mondes du lissage
de ce qui tend vers le bas ce que nous
vivons est ce que nous sommes nous
sommes tous avec un potentiel de
créativité pour les uns d'audace de
prise de risque pour les autres on a
tout ça au fond de nous je crois que que
ce soit dans la politique comme ailleurs
il faut réveiller cette capacité
d'audace est captée de créativité et que
la confiance qu'ont à vis à vis les
autres se fait aussi à l'aune de la
deûle à de l'audace de sa capacité de
notre capacité osé le troisième vecteur
de confiance c'est la détermination et
là je voudrais remettre un peu dans le
contexte de ma campagne en 2008 à
quelques à quelques mois du premier tour
alors que la campagne était dur a été
violente parce que j'étais un homme
libre dans un monde qui est quand même
très structuré par des partis politiques
je me retrouve dans le bureau du
président de la république qui me
proposent d'apaiser la tension à
condition que je rentre dans un parti je
lui dit non que je tiens par dessus tout
à ma liberté et que je n'ai pas peur de
perdre et que je veux surtout gagner
qu'avec la confiance de mes électeurs si
on ne rien devoir ni un président ni un
menteur ni à un parent ni un parti et
quand je sors de ce rendez vous qui
avait été dur je retrouve mes équipes et
la confiance se démultiplie ils me
disent tu as montré ta détermination tu
as montré que finalement tu n'avais pas
peur de perdre et que rien ne pouvait
arrêter ta détermination et 12 dans nos
vies il ya des moments où on peut
renoncer il ya des gens qu'on soupçonne
de pouvoir abandonner en cours de route
et c'est je crois un élément fondamental
quelqu'un qui montre sa détermination
attise la confiance et on a besoin de
cette détermination conviction audace
détermination et pour terminer je
voudrais partager avec vous un échange
que j'ai eu au début de ma de mon
parcours politique avec un journaliste
que je recevais dans ma mairie de nîmes
et qui me dit quand même qu'est ce que
vous avez comme recette pour être élu
totalement libre en dehors de tous les
systèmes politiques pour être élu maire
j'étais élue députée après je suis aussi
élu dans un département pour porter des
grands projets en échappant totalement
aux circuits officiels et en fin de
compte que j'avais moi même pas vraiment
analyser les causes de cette de 7,2
cette confiance qui m'était accordé je
lui dit vous savez je crois que il ya
une qualité qu'on peut tous partager
c'est
l'émerveillement quand c'est
s'émerveiller et quand c'est partager
notre émerveillement en regardant tout
ce qui est beau tout ce bien commun
qu'on a en partage un paysage les
montagnes à sourire d'enfant une belle
réalisation d'un artisan à belfort ou
ailleurs quand on sait partager ce qui
est beau quand on sait partager son
émerveillement qu'on a le sens de
l'émerveillement alors la confiance est
partagée également je crois et c'est
peut-être ce qu'il faut retenir que les
convictions laudun sa détermination sont
des vecteurs sont des outils formidables
qui doivent nous habiter mais en même
temps si on n'a pas les émerveillements
on n'a pas la confiance merci